qui salue la mémoire de centaines de
milliers de soldats qui ont qui sont
tombés ici qu'ils aimaient leur patrie
qui créent et qui était fier de la
russie pays d'une civilisation unique et
à la culture si riche
un pays qui unit désespoir le destin les
espoirs de beaucoup de générations et
nous sommes les héritiers de cette
histoire qui date de plusieurs
millénaires et nous savons que comme
nous sont ensemble même dans les
situations les plus difficiles au coude
à coude avec les plus éprouvés nous
pouvons résoudre les difficultés les
plus grandes
ces derniers temps nous avons résolu un
certain nombre de problèmes importants
et je crois qu'aujourd'hui à la veille
du de l'élection du référendum sur les
amendements à la constitution
nous sommes face à un choix important il
ne s'agit pas seulement de normes
juridiques mais nous choisissons nous
faisons un choix vote pour le pays
le pi dans lesquelles nous avons grandi
pour plus de protection des citoyens
pour que les autorités puissent rendre
compte à la population dans un pays dans
lequel nous travaillons et que nous
voulons remettre à nos enfants et je
suis convaincu que chacun d'entre vous
participent à ce référendum en pensant
premièrement à ses proches aux valeurs
qui nous unissent tous c'est la vérité
et la justice et le respect du travail
de chacun le respect des anciens le
respect de la famille des enfants de
leur santé et de leur éducation
spirituelle et morale
si vous soutenez les amendements ces
valeurs seront attachés elles seront
fixées dans la constitution comme
référence supérieurs la stabilité
et la préférence et cela nous ne pouvons
le assuré que via un travail continu et
c'est notre responsabilité c'est notre
sens nos sentiments sincères d'un
patriotisme que nous exprimons ici pour
la souveraineté de la russie est en même
temps le respect pour son histoire pour
son pour sa culture pour sa langue et
pour ses réalisations et l'héritage
légué par nos anciens tout cela fait que
le texte renouvelée de la constitution
n'entrera en vigueur que si vous
approuvez ce choix vous savez que le
scrutin se déroule déjà depuis plusieurs
jours et sept mesures s'imposent pour
protéger la santé des gens je remercie
ceux qui ont déjà exprimé leur choix et
demain le 1er juillet sera le jour
principal du scrutin et je vous demande
chers amis de donner votre voix chaque
chaque voix chacun d'entre vous est
important
je vous remercie